quand j'étais plus jeune le côté un peu
porno pouvait un peu m'amuser à 18-19
ans moi j'ai plein de clients
moi mon préféré mon préféré s'appelle
Kevin Warhol Kevin
je sortais deux fois moi avec des
acteurs gay c'est vrai que deux fois
deux semaines
et puis l'autre je vais pas vous dire
son nom mais c'est États-Unis
après ça peut te ça peut te poursuivre
pour ta carrière non mais t'inquiète pas
ça vous aurait pu traîner ma carrière je
veux dire quand on a fait ouf
[Rires]
tu en as vu des curieux
dans l'émission dans l'émission dans
l'émission
c'est pas mal aujourd'hui
[Rires]
c'était qui ton ami non parce que
tu vas voir je vais flinguer ton mariage
je voulais savoir si vous avez déjà
fréquenté une actrice de films
pornographiques non non
mais j'ai valise moi j'ai fréquenté par
exemple
[Applaudissements]
là on peut pas laisser ça comme ça il y
a un litige là les gens de droite
même les publics vous allez vous faire
ruer dans pas longtemps là
Cyril on fait la télé pour les gens
savez ce qui m'a sorti pour vous dire
qu'il a rien dans le slip il m'a dit je
te balance l'autre là mais qui l'autre
je sais pas tu me croises
on ne parle qu'est-ce qu'il y a toi
[Rires]
elle est toujours vivante
vous êtes expert en fait
86 derniers films mais il est cinéphile
longue relation
pas du tout c'est très très court
es
[Applaudissements]
trouve tout de suite vraiment
on est connu
golden voilà il y a bien sûr
il y a
voilà tu peux me citer autant de poète
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr il y a Tiffany Hopkins
elle est elle est dans celle que j'ai
dit est-ce que sans donner parce que
maintenant
est-ce que ça
c'est bon c'est fini bon